the Joe Rogan experience I love Irish
people man
I just I'm [ __ ] fascinated by the
wildness of that culture well yeah
that's what God made whiskey you know so
the Irish would so the Irish would never
rule the world when you see a guy like a
guy like Conor McGregor that part of
what is him is Irish
he's like a pure like brilliant Irish
you know I'm talking for sure balls fall
the way [ __ ] knows rock a loss
knows how to take a loss takes a loss
like a man it's still talk [ __ ] you know
I'm right back to my is it it's like
that you know that that guy that you
fight but he loses but you know you're
gonna have to fight him tomorrow yes or
as soon as his [ __ ] is healed up and the
busted up Ness is gone it's kinda like a
hundred million dollars in the bank he
still wants a fight people still smack
him people at bars yeah that step don't
do that no not that who knows what the
[ __ ] the guy said to him but it looked
like the guy was old as [ __ ] someone
said he was only 50 that the guy was
only 50 dude didn't fold up though he
just kind of sat at the bar Connor in
really yeah he's arrested he gave him
this smack in the back and a couple of
fingers he touched you do what we call
mush them you mush them yes you can kind
of be interpreted as hitting but it
really Kwok ain't quite a hit yeah when
you're a guy like that you're basically
walking around agreeing not to [ __ ]
people up because you have to kind of
agree to not [ __ ] people up the money
he's got there should be like five guys
around him to make sure that never
happens yeah but they can't listen to
him like if you have a guy like him he's
gonna do whatever he wants even if
there's a bunch of people around him
stop at him you're not gonna stop them
from doing checks when he threw that
guy's phone down the ground stomped it
in Miami there was all the bodyguards
there he just did it he just did it he's
Conor McGregor he's [ __ ] look he's
living like you're supposed to live if
you're Connor Gregor the dance is don't
go to jail dude don't get locked up it's
also the the whole structure of the way
things are now as far as like
entertainment it's like the guy it's all
about eyeballs
well he
didn't figured it out man pull the knife
figured like in the most crazy way
possible he figured out how to just blow
up the whole system when you're a guy
who has been fightin I contacted him on
Twitter in like 2013 right by 2018 he's
worth a hundred million dollars so quick
and he called it all the way and he
calls it all the way that's the crazy as
far as I'll look he called it all the
way like I'm gonna be you know a
billionaire I'm a multi-millionaire
you know what Dana White said to me once
about him that's dead-on he said he eats
pressure he said that guy eats pressure
he just eats it he goes he just he just
goes in there and then the more pressure
experiences the better he can perform
it's true it's like you look at the Aldo
fight picture perfect left-hand knockout
it doesn't get any prettier the timing
is set up the patience the movement the
setting it up looking for him to leap in
and blame catching the money's coming
and pretty sure he said exactly those
that's exactly what he said he was gonna
do right before the fight - oh that's me
tweeting him in January of 2013
I saw his fight in I think it was Cage
Warriors I think that's the promotion
cage wars are Cage Warriors I think it's
why am i [ __ ] that up cage wars is it
two different ones there probably is
this is probably a bunch of cage stuff
but in either way he was a [ __ ]
people up overseas I was like this kids
for real he just sees something
sometimes he sees like I watch a video
see how a guy moves I'm like Jesus
some guys just have something and he had
just ridiculous timing yeah they're so
relaxed in there those were fun fights
man his early days of MMA is like you
can go back and watch him and you go oh
this guy's gonna be special he's got
like a weird sense of timing you know
it's like he's just very good at
understanding where you're at
no not to put it all he's had me when
and you know that I were you know how
Irish thing that's it oh for sure me too
situation
love it I love it
yeah when he was like we all fight
together look when he's in the room like
if he wins a fight and there's you know
the crowds filled with like 7,000 Irish
people do you feel it like you feel like
goose bumps it's crazy like you do
everything you can to stop just to keep
yourself from crying at the beauty of it
this guy's standing there in front of
thousands of people that have flown
overseas dancing I only people fly over
dude it's crazy they take over the
[ __ ] Vegas hotels take over like will
you have seized the finish shut the only
7th Avenue in front of in front of
Madison Square Garden
there's not a [ __ ] fan on earth like
Irish fans they're different
I said think Brazilian fans were crazy
until I saw the Irish fans they take
over the whole Mandalay Bay was taken
over by people singing it was all it was
a fair amount of drinking Oh fair more
than fair but just the fact that they
could do that that they can gang get
together and sing the same song like
thousands of them together singing the
same song I remember the first time when
we went to Ireland as House of Pain and
uh in between saws they broke into the
whole you know all the soccer chant
stuff oh my and we were just like wow
this is crazy you know we never
experienced anything like that they
don't they had you didn't do that at the
sports events at home back then not back
then at all so that was amazing
culturally it's it's it's it's it's that
soccer - it is real Connor fight in
Ireland once he's got to fight in Dublin
in a soccer stadium [ __ ] yet right why
not why not if he's ever gonna fight
again that's why I do it I don't you
know that I think the idea was that it's
like more money and pay-per-view if you
fight in Vegas you know in Vegas is
worth a lot of money he doesn't the time
have a lot to do with it - when they got
a European thing they're gonna do the
whole weird time thing over there so
they can accommodate the pay-per-view
here yeah I'd be real weird they'd be
fighting like 4:00 in the morning it's
always real weird to me when I wake up
and there's like a South America fight
that happened at noon and I'm like
yeah I missed